I was older single man and it gets sad
around the house sometimes we're just
like two lonely hearts haunting the same
hallway we barely talk to each other
just passing the night it gets sad like
the other I recently caught him making
pancakes for himself that's not a single
man fed that's for your family your
beautiful wife Janine and I'm saying
your boys just won a hockey championship
yeah and slice up strawberries you have
a nice time you know someone lonely man
looking out the window
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm gonna take turkey cheddar lettuce
tomato pickles mayo and mustard on hard
roll please
thank you is that a hard roll is that
the turkey cheddar tomato lettuce
mayonnaise and mustard pickles if you
got them ten bucks
okay there's a 20 and
I'm not gonna eat that
hey none sir can you two steak tacos
extra sour cream and they'll do it thank
you
so thrilled to have him here brother
ladies and gentlemen Ryan
you always hear this from older guys to
go old college that's the best time in
your life I was trying to figure out why
older guys always tell you that college
is the best time in your life and I
think it's because college is the only
time in your life as a man when the
women are attracted to potential after
that they're very results-oriented
my favorite class that I took in college
was a Black Studies course but the whole
dynamic of the class was just like me
and one other white dude in an
auditorium full of black people and then
one day as part of the class we got
tested on all of the racial stereotypes
for black people throughout all of
history and they hand out the tests and
then I started to fill it out and I
realized like oh I should not be the
first one to turn this in am I trying to
make eyes the other white guy in class
like no you go first you go first hey
man I did what's going on how much has
your night pretty good had to do a gig
about you all right sucks bro
what's wrong
oh wait me mean I don't say that
did something someone well what do I
have to do you look at me what do I have
to do I'm out here every day trying my
hardest and then all the girls all
these gross guys I've been there brother
I don't know don't you tell you sorry
you've been there yeah nice tall guy
like you hey what happens to me I bet
you never jerk-off I gotta sit at home
and I got a jerk-off every night I'm 35
years old and I jerk off all over the
goddamn room all over the room huh I've
jerked off every day for three years
just sitting my room jerk with my dick
mean well stuff what do I gotta do mean
tell me what I gotta do please please
please you want advice you want yes okay
yes listen you're a very nice guy you're
friendly no positive qualities but
there's one thing you're covering rice
dude and I feel like that's a big part
of it I do mean why though you think I
don't know that I'm covered in rice
everybody tells me I'm coming in right
so I'm a messy eater you know that
you're covering right I love rice that
doesn't mean I don't deserve love just
because I like to eat right man well you
figure
my mom's house drinking on for the rest
of my life because I can't eat rice just
too much rice cool we kissed uh we
adopted a dog which has been she's so
sweet I love that we rescued the dog
that's what you got to do you got to
rescue the dogs because it is cheaper
just so much fever $75 for my best
friend you give this city 75 bucks and
then all you got to do is check a box
that says that you won't use the dog as
a food source that's it that's all you
got to do I was like look if we're gonna
we were gonna eat her we we want to get
a bigger one everybody you're gonna love
this guy put your hands together for
James
[Applause]
Rep hero boys
[Music]